one of the busiest cargo gateways in the
country the port of los angeles is once
again seeing bottlenecks that could
disrupt the supply chain the businesses
and consumers nationwide this time it's
because of a shortage of rail workers as
carter evans shows us the disruptions
could eventually be even worse than what
we saw at the height of the pandemic
tis the season for ships packed with
holiday gifts to start flooding
america's ports but the containers are
already piling up clogging the docks
waiting for trains to transport cargo
across the country there are about 35
thousand containers that are designated
for rail on our docks right now on a
normal day looks more like 9 000 units
la port director gene soroca is sounding
the alarm to prevent another scene like
this how long before we see it back up
at sea again we've probably got another
four to six weeks if we do nothing over
the last three years railroads have lost
20 percent of their employees a lot of
that is because they cut their own
workforce
analyst ben nolan says it began when
they tried to streamline operations with
a practice called precision scheduled
railroading when you're
hyper efficient you're ill prepared for
unexpected things like pandemics so
where are the bottlenecks right now the
bottlenecks right now are on that last
mile union pacific operations vp eric
garinger says his railroad has already
hired hundreds of new employees we're
handling that volume resources beyond
the railroad that's where we need to see
gains the rails move containers inland
where merchandise is transferred and
delivered but with truck driver
shortages and now a glut of goods
arriving the warehouses are full there's
nowhere to offload the goods and the
containers keep coming is it going to
get any worse that number continues to
grow
every day every week would more trains
here help absolutely but you have to
have somewhere to put the trains when
they get to their destination and none
of it will happen without railroad
workers who've been working without a
contract for two years now with no
raises an emergency team from the white
house will offer its recommendations in
the next two weeks in hopes of heading
off a railroad strike in september
for cbs mornings i'm carter evans in los
angeles